[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number
65 q a segment we are now going to
address
questions with answers hopefully
there'll be a match
yes our dog is a question yes what is
the question
why do only the cats get the cream at
the beginning of the
q a um because the dog will put up with
not getting the cream that's
unfortunately the answer that's not
nice it's not no she gets plenty of love
though yep
yeah yeah we got a um a slew of cats on
the back counter
uh drinking cream right now there you
have it all right
with a short supply chain high quality
cream
yeah it's pretty short it's pretty short
it's uh it's at least pacific northwest
originated cows yeah
all right we are going to start as we do
with a few questions and comments that
we didn't get to in episode 64.
then we'll pick up a question from the
discord server this week and then
launch into questions from last hour
before finishing up the questions from
this hour so um
first question i actually have not
looked at these again since
last week we're just gonna keep
with the same theme of today
what is the light what are the likely
scenarios going forward
if the vaccines don't work against a
mutated coronavirus
um great great question and i think and
i think this
this really should be the topic of a
whole of a whole episode
um and it's part it's part of where
we're going with diet and activity
right like change your lifestyle
such that you are in the best health
to mitigate the severity of the symptoms
should you be exposed
um and then there are also of course
some
treatments which are different from
vaccines vaccines are prophylactic and
treatments are
for you know post-exposure that really
are super promising
you know we've talked about before here
ivermectin
that i think may well
be incredibly powerful in dealing with
um some some of the effects of
uh this disease in in some people
probably not all well i take the
question a little bit
differently and yes there's a lot you
can do to make covid
better and to avoid getting it but um
you know what if the vaccines fail to
control covid which i think is a real
possibility
i'm especially concerned that it seems
like at least
the four vaccines that are out or on the
horizon
all seem to target the same the spike
protein
and my concern is that effectively what
you've done
is created a very intense evolutionary
signal that will cause evolution of the
virus in response to the vaccines
so you really have to hit them hard
in order for the vaccine to deliver
enough of a blow
that it would solve the problem and
short of that i do expect we will see
evolution in response to it i think
there's some
nightmare scenarios uh
you know will some of the world give up
and decide to let kovid go to
equilibrium and
you know evolution will ultimately sort
it out in a different way
and then some other part of the world
you know
new zealand australia places that have
been successful in controlling it
will they effectively be uh you know
the elite landscape that doesn't have to
live
under either threat of covid or
intense controls but also no longer i
mean
then you're going to have much more
closed borders
than right you have now i mean not that
you have now than you had a year ago
right so i i think that there you know
there are some scary scenarios i also
think it's possible
that we um
begin to develop a program in other
words we may have to chase covid
with you know it's not like will the
vaccines won't work or won't they work
it's like well maybe we need a program
in which the vaccines
uh target covid in a coordinated way
going forward we learn from each
iteration and we ultimately chase it out
of existence or something like that um
but i'm concerned you know my sense is
what should have happened here is that
as soon as we knew
what we were dealing with right really
had a good sense of it
um we should have gone into a
hyper-vigilant state and controlled it
while it was not widespread
that it's like an invasive species that
once it's widespread it's
very hard to deal with and
um yeah hey i hope we learn that lesson
for next time but
with respect to this one i would say
we've always got to realize as bad as
this is
it can be worse and the more we
mismanage it the worse it's going to be
and so um anyway i think it is worth
exploring what happens if these vaccines
don't work
um and that that ought to spook us into
figuring out
uh you know the price the price only
gets
larger for dealing with it and we should
address it as soon as possible
okay next question from episode 64.
how do we end junk science like junk
social science and junk climate science
i've lost almost all trust in science
because of these fields
there's no simple how because the
institutions that award the degrees that
confer scientific authority on some
people
are corrupt and broken and in fact many
of these fields have forgotten how to do
science
they've moved on and um
or yes they've forgotten or they've
moved on
or they have intentionally and convinced
themselves this is how it always was
conflated um you know results with
process
uh and or decided that data driven
is what science is and always has been
as opposed to hypothesis driven
yep um so how do you rescue it well
you're going to need to find some way to
isolate
some people who know how to do science
from the market forces that tend to
disrupt
the the doing of proper science and uh
i don't know what that's going to look
like or where it's going to be but the
first people who can
bootstrap that insulation are going to
have a huge advantage
in the 21st century and so anyway that's
sort of a challenge yes it's not easy to
figure out what you do
when your universities are compromised
but it means that
having done it you'd have a huge
advantage and there's a big incentive
there for
to to figure out how to solve the
problem yeah
uh brett this question is for you you
believe that lack of clear geographical
divides
that reflect political divides would
result in violence in the case of a
national divorce like secession
please describe what this would look
like
well i don't know what this would look
like
is i think the point is you have
populations that can't figure out how to
get along
that are not separated by geography and
so there's no natural division so what
will it look like it will look like
us you know fighting neighbor against
neighbor which
is just not an easily resolved problem
so
it's not an easily resolved problem
although at a very
broad level very broad brush um sort of
you know the coasts
are often quite different in politics
from
uh you know even 100 miles inland
yeah but what do you do with that i mean
for one thing
you know we've seen the uh the west
coast at least has demonstrated
that um when it attempts to govern based
on
its understanding of things that uh
it results in collapse of
civil authority so
i don't know is it good if
those on the coast can isolate their
arrogance i'm not saying it's good i'm
just saying that there there isn't
as much uh intermingling
of uh of the kinds of political
divisions that
uh this person is talking about i think
um
at a less granular level than you might
think
although i mean i guess i would argue
that actually
um really i mean since before evergreen
blew up but especially since then
the the number and diversity of people
from
you know any demographic that you can
think of including political
um that reach out to us and say uh
you know i i i appreciate your ability
to have
a conversation in which you don't
conflate you know disagreement with
dislike for the other person
but also will then like reveal
two beliefs that they have that simply
don't fit the ideologies that we're told
that everyone has
and certainly it looks you know the
complete lack
of unity in the country where you know
if you
if you are um
[Music]
i don't even want to start listing
things and like trigger people in a bad
way but like
you know we we we know that we can like
list blue team stuff and you can go down
the list and assume that if someone
believes in
item one they're going to believe in all
of them and same thing with red team
and actually i think at least the people
who are paying attention to us and maybe
that's a
strong sort of confirmation bias and you
know and strong selection here um but
people
are not actually nearly as ideological
as as
it would seem there are a whole lot of
people who are actually trying
to deduce what their values are and what
they think is true from first principles
and saying
yeah you know what um this might be
comfortable but i'm pro-choice
and i also understand that uh you know
2a you know amendment 2a is necessary
and
yeah i can say both of those things at
the same time so i think the question
what you're talking about is the the
dominant truth here which is the
the exhausted middle the 67 percent in
the middle that
overwhelmingly agree on a nuanced
intermediate uh version of all of these
things it's the fringes that can't get
along at
all between which there is no obvious
divorce possible because of the
geographic intermingling
okay maybe that's maybe maybe that's it
then yeah
yeah okay the next one is just a comment
that equity and this person posits is
the same as reparations
yeah i've said that um reparations
all the time in every interaction at
every scale
the problem is it's not even reparations
though
it is um
the theme is reparations but
from whom to whom is
not something that has been worked out
in other words we're going to use the
proxy
of race which we're told doesn't mean
anything
which isn't true but we're going to you
know it's definitely a broken measure
we're going to use something we've been
told as a fiction but we're going to use
it um to fix a problem which is not
fictional
right the problem really isn't fictional
but then how is the thing a total
fiction
yeah we're going to use it we're going
to use it without any understanding of
what the objective is how
we'll know when we reach it we're going
to use it in spite of the fact that
game theoretically you cannot run a
reparations
program inside of a classroom right if
you want to
if you reparations are a good idea you
have to do it at large scale and
distribute the
um the costs in a fair way you cannot do
it in every conversation in every
uh hiring committee in every classroom
you just can't do it so
anyway it's a recipe for disaster but
yes i think
the idea is there are harms
they are real they are being
oversimplified and used as a
justification
for a ubiquitous um
peer-to-peer enforced reparations
program that we have not
agreed to or anything like that and it
can't help it in a disaster
yeah okay final question from episode 64
is do you think that language has an
impact on the rise of trans
transgenderism i'm a native french
speaker and languages of latin roots do
not have a genderless pronoun like it
they assign genders to all nouns this
makes debate very different
um in that there's little to none of the
demand for new and non-binary
pronouns in the french culture for
example
i i think this is fascinating it's sort
of a
it's sort of a sapir wharf hypothesis
take on uh
rising politics uh that your that your
language may actually inform
what kinds of uh cultural change you are
you are striving for
well i think so there are a couple ways
to interpret this
um i think one thing that is true is if
you do have
you know gendered nouns in your language
it is clear that the fact that mesa is
female doesn't it's not really about
gender in the same sense as sex it is
just a categorization scheme
it's actually an error correction for
language so that you know
you know what modifies what it allows
you to
convey information more robustly
and the fact that the table is female
and not male is arbitrary it could just
as easily work the other way
and so the i think the sense of what
role
you know how much flexibility there is
may well be you know i agree yeah
there's sort of a weaks up your
warf meaning that your your language
structures what you can perceive
there's an implication what exactly the
implication is i don't know
it's certainly the case that until the
last time we went to
south america i don't think in any of
our travels to central and south america
we had encountered
[Music]
trans ideological anything
and then a year ago last month we were
in ecuador
certainly didn't run into it in the
amazon yeah or in uh
or in cuenca but in quito the one day we
spent in quito that's right
there was some graffiti about honoring
trans lives or something yeah
but by and large you know when we took
students
uh to south america there was of course
you know the suggestion made that we you
know
that we try to speak neutered spanish
and and all of this occasionally i mean
that was actually only on on the last
trip i
never heard right right before that's my
point that came
from uh well
you know white kids it this is not
something there's not
as far as we see a movement of people in
latin america
trying to fix the evils of the gendered
language
or asking to be referred to as latinx
right exactly so
you know this is something that's being
imposed on the situation but
you know is it finally leaking into you
know keto to the extent that you and i
would run into a little bit of graffiti
i guess so but that's quite new it's
it's lagging behind
yeah um okay
from the discord this week um people
pose questions and they get voted on
and this one won for this week what are
your thoughts on homeschooling
with wokeness taking over public
education could it be a good idea to
form secular homeschool pods that focus
on classical liberal education
with groups of parents sharing the
educational load
100 yeah absolutely and we have
a ton to say about this um we had a lot
of homeschooled kids
at evergreen actually and you know
mostly this was not um
these are not people from religious
backgrounds a few of them i think but
mostly it was
it was this kind of thing um you know
also unschooled
um also kids from you know waldorf and
montessori and sudbury traditions
and you know all kids in all of those
traditions homeschooled and unschooled
and
these somewhat alternative
private educational systems
people who had experienced those things
tended to be
internally motivated and creative
and analytical and competent and
appropriately confident
and um certainly there will be
exceptions and
you know i'm not claiming that it's you
know that anyone in traditional
schooling
uh was there for none of those things
you know we are both the product of
you know some excellent and some
terrible um schooling but all of it you
know more
traditional than any of those things
but yeah homeschooling if
if the parents have the time
and the wherewithal well i like the
suggestion here
of uh teaming up to do this properly
well it reminds me we did
it was in school but we did this thing
um at our back in olympia
and our neighbors our our good friends
um
karen and andrea initiation we did
something called family camp
for several years uh where we had three
and then four families
so either five or seven kids um and
we basically ran each of the families
ran a five day day camp each year
during the summer so that each of the
families got basically
three weeks of paid child care with with
families
whom they you know respected and
appreciated and we all played to our
strengths
so you know we we took kids to the zoo
and we took them biking and we took them
to an organic farm one year
and you know we spent a lot of time
outside and
um one of the families did theater and
baseball
and one um often took them to the lake
and we're teaching them swimming and
it was just fabulous and yes that was
camp it was during the summer and it
wasn't expected to be academic
um but of course you know that's those
are often the situations where you learn
tremendously and that worked wonderfully
yeah in this case though
there is the opening and in fact if our
kids were younger it would make a lot of
sense
at this point to do it which is to
gather
to put some resources to the problem
even if what you're effectively doing
is privately sourcing education that
isn't polluted by nonsense
this is not only um one way to get
what's essential
for your kids but i hate to say
it i don't want anybody's kids to fail
but
the thing that is being done to kids in
regular school both public and private
at this point
is a kind of mental sabotage
it is leading you know feeding children
conclusions that are demonstrably false
and insisting that they accept them
is uh it is going to result in a
misprogramming of those minds
maybe it will it will result in a you
know
a wonderful rebellion at some point it
could result in a
terrible rebellion yeah but
the idea that well nothing's more
important
than making sure that your kids have
excellent tools with which to
go into an uncertain world gathering
with other parents pooling your
resources
hiring people who aren't crazy to teach
them
makes a lot of sense and i would say do
it and don't think of it as
homeschooling whatever they call it
whatever
you have to do in order to make it
legitimate in the eyes of the state
figure it out but you know school
without garbage
is really important because the
alternative
you know isn't so much unschooling
or you know even homeschooling which has
downsides in the sense that it isolates
kids and so they miss certain
uh lessons there but you know ultimately
you're gonna be faced
uh with de-schooling kids you know right
yeah no not on school like d-schooling
just um
de-programming them from what they what
they get um
in school and you know better just to
get it right in the first place
all right um now we go
to questions from this last hour
our friend dave says how cool is the
green room on the real time set
parentheses you guys did great well
the real time set they they are under
such effective covet regulations they
apparently they were the first
to the the first big studio to reopen
um and i asked actually i asked one of
the staff um how often they get cover
tested so we were co-tested twice in a
bit like once before getting
once 48 hours before getting on the
plane and then once right before
and that's standard and apparently
they're tested two or three times a week
every every uh crew member and certainly
cast as well
um but it also means that like there's
just
everything is different than it would
normally be yeah everything is
everything is different and you know
they they've
cut back obviously they don't have an
audience they have staff members
playing the part of the audience and
they were all apologetic about the lack
of sociality
right yeah so the green room you didn't
have didn't have snacks you know we had
we had
we had a nice little spread in our
dressing room but there's no after party
there was like
there was just a lot less than there
would have been normally for which there
was
abject apology frequently yeah i mean i
still i was impressed i mean in fact
you know um this is amazing this is uh
this is a real time hand sanitizer my
one complex actually it's good stuff
it does not it's not the kind that
leaves your hand sticky it's high
quality sanitizer but
nowhere on here is there a warning not
to store this
with your ketchup packets and so that's
a mistake you make once
um i can tell you you don't think hand
sanitizer wouldn't be a little bit like
vinegar like maybe you want vinegar or
hand sanitizer or ketchup on your fries
yeah it's not like vinegar at all i
would say okay um i don't know i've
actually
never made that mistake well when you do
think of this moment but anyway yeah so
the the things are not normal there yeah
they are impressive i do think that
there is a major
lesson you know here you've got a um
a very big important program that
clearly had a conversation with itself
how can we go back to doing this
under these conditions without covid
being in any way resolved
and it clearly costs money and they
clearly
limit the things that they do that they
once did
but we're looking forward to doing again
soon right but they are
totally up and running and i must tell
you there's something
um a little
hard to put one's finger on but awfully
important our experience of
intersecting with uh with real time
and you know being tested twice you
don't have covid
you don't have covet there was a relief
just like it's the only
period of two days we experienced really
it's like oh
don't come in right and it's not like we
think we have covered most of the time
but just simply even knowing for two
days
well in that period totally free of
covet is actually
it puts you in a mentally different
place and knowing that everybody that
you're interacting with has been
recently tested and therefore constantly
tested yeah um
you know the precautions are really just
precautions and it's not like you know i
wonder
who around here is you know coughing out
uh
viral particles um so the point is look
let's suppose we stopped [ __ ] around
and we said all right
we've got a serious problem what
resources will it take to get us
back up and running without creating
further covet disaster
what would it take to do what real time
has done with its program
and to do the equivalent for a great
many things
right and it's conceivable it costs
money on the other hand
i think what we're doing is costing
money what we're doing is costing it's
costing money without getting us
anywhere
yeah and so uh i would advocate that
those who have figured out how to do
this
on some scale i mean you know these
i do not know the expected false
negative rate on these rapid tests but
these rapid tests which is what they're
experiencing
the the cast and crew are getting two or
three times a week and which is what the
the second test that we got are it's
literally it's less than 15 minutes so
you know depending on how expensive they
are
could could that start to be deployed
for restaurants
for theaters for you know for
for for live entertainment well and you
could you know
imagine that you um maybe this is what
you're thinking
but imagine that there was some uh
app or something that each time you got
a test that was validated and in these
cases they were very careful to make
sure that we were who we said we were so
that
somebody else couldn't take your test
for you and you know everything every
sample was carefully
tracked barcodes so that we knew exactly
that on this moment the test is negative
and that um could
be something that you could opt into
and the point is in order to do certain
things
your negative test in some period of
time
could simply be registered somewhere
such that you're
greenlit for this thing and you could
you know in a week when you weren't
going to intersect with things maybe you
don't do it
yeah and a test that's not invasive
that's not introducing anything
um and uh that obviously gets out of
date and you know as soon as
as soon as you take it but
really really could begin
depending on how actually accurate they
are what the rate of false negatives
um i guess and false pauses but
specifically false negatives would be
the risk to you know
to the community um are and um
and how cheaply such a thing could be
deployed well
i think the rate of false negatives
should be very very low with one
exception
so this is a pcr test which means that
it amplifies very tiny signals
of viral genes
and so you're likely to get a fair
number of false positives potentially
but false negatives would be rare
as others have pointed out you may have
fragments
that are there long after you're sick
and so you could get false positives
if you've been exposed if you had if you
had had coveted or had been severely
exposed
but false negatives i would imagine
would be mostly people who are
pre-symptomatic
but as our friend and former student
jeff ladich points out
the seriousness of that is relatively
reduced because if you're in
a you know a very early state where
there's not enough
of the virus to be detected by this test
you're also not highly infectious
right right if you if you both have no
symptoms and your viral load is low
it's you know there may be some third
way by which the thing is transmitting
but those seem to be
um the the likely indicators of
infectiousness right
but anyway regardless i feel like there
might be something else but
yeah a we could test the methodology we
could say you know
real time and whoever else has figured
out how to get their business up and
running in a context where there are
lots and lots of people interacting and
they need to do it safely and you're
you know bringing people i mean you know
the biggest danger we experienced was
surely the plane um but
uh the the question of how to do it
and how effective that is at preventing
transmission and how much
more effective we would be this is one
of the things i was hoping would come up
last night on on real time that that we
didn't get to
but the failure to get high quality
tests
regularly enough administered that we
could in fact look
at the um the epidemiology in real time
as it were
and deal with outbreaks more rapidly
rather than waiting for people to show
up
you know to get a test because they've
come down with something right
would be very useful so i don't know why
we're not doing this
but the fact that it can be done in
small pockets when there's enough
on the line tells us that there's
something that we might be thinking
about for
civilization that would be well worth
considering absolutely
all right let's uh get a move on we've
only gotten through one question and
zach we're probably already at a half an
hour or so right
now yeah so obviously we're gonna keep
going here but um
uh youtuber garippi claims that robert
trivers endorsed his book the
revolutionary phenotype
after reading the book i doubt the
validity of its thesis and the trovers
actually endorsed it
what are your thoughts uh this we have
not read it uh we have we have engaged
uh we've been asked to read it and we've
been sent it and
um we just have not gotten around to it
so i i don't have much to say here let's
let's hold on i certainly don't want to
answer for bob
um and can't answer for myself so yes
let's
uh return to it yeah next one in a
similar vein jar jar binks
has forward-facing eyes on two-inch
fleshy stalks extending above his skull
but he walks upright on dry land seems
wildly unlucky for a species one bad
stumble and you're blind
could jar jar have ever evolved
this is a great question yeah i wish i
knew more about the star wars universe
star wars right is that where jordan yes
okay i know it's on star trek i just
like i think it's star wars
um i know i wish i knew more about the
star wars universe to know exactly what
his
you know what he's doing besides walking
around on dry land but
um certainly by you know what i do have
in my mind's eye and what this
description suggests
uh it does seem rather unlikely
rather unlikely yeah i think rather
unlikely i mean the real question is
can't i mean
frankly i couldn't pick jar jar out of a
lineup so i can't really speak to
whether he could have evolved i really
don't i don't remember much but
um but the real question is you know can
you come up with a plausible
habitat and niche that would fit his
weird morphology
um there he is
well jeez i mean i mean he's really low
slung like that
just the um that's the first image i've
got if he's low slung like a
like a turtle um it's not it's not such
a problem
um but yeah so here i'm hesitant i'm
hesitant to say
oh no he's not necessarily lost long
here he's being ridden so clearly we
just don't know enough star wars like i
said like
this i mean this is what you know the
the evolutionary answer to a question
like this requires that you know
something about the environment in which
the organism is
yeah yeah yeah i'm more skeptical of uh
r2d2 um having done what evolving
yeah more or less he's an extension of
the engineers who put him together
it's clearly a wheeled vehicle
on tiny wheels tiny wheels are too small
tips over sometimes
sorry not buying it it's like have you
ever rollerbladed in the desert it's
like
yeah it just doesn't work yeah again
it's like the
the um ketchup packets and mixing them
with your hand sanitizer it's a mistake
you make once
is that what it's like exactly like that
okay
if next question kovid came from the lab
how much information about the virus was
known by the scientist in the lab
is it a crime against the world who have
withheld any useful information about
the virus from the beginning
penalty question mark uh yeah this more
or less goes to the distinction i was
trying to draw earlier which is
a i mean look escape from the lab could
mean anything it could mean
a sample was transported um from
you know the mine in yunnan
and escaped in its natural form
that doesn't fit the evidence but lab
leak would include that
in which case somebody might have known
exactly nothing about it other than
its source on the other hand if this was
the result of serial passage experiments
and gain of function research they would
have known an awful lot about it
um is it um what's the phraseology is it
crime well i think it certainly is at
the national level if
if the chinese government prevented
scientists from
sharing the information they had then
that is
uh tantamount to a major crime against
the rest of the world
again we've got a failure of the
international scientific community here
if this is what happened
though those outside of china might not
know for sure
but again
at the point that somebody knows that
the virus is the result of some
experiment they have run
and it is out in the world i think yes
absolutely there is a
100 percent moral obligation to share
the information about
what led to that virus so that we have
the most information possible
to fight it in terms of power it seems
like basic ethics
yeah basic research ethics absolutely
basic yeah and
you know i don't care what it does to
your research program look at what
covet is doing to the world yeah
whatever your research program is is not
more important than that
um in terms of penalty
it's a little hard to say the most
important thing is this can never happen
again
and that means that the incentives need
to be whatever they are what we don't
want to do
is create a scenario in which
information that is known is not shared
in other words if we had to trade
you know if we had to effectively do uh
truth and reconciliation in order to get
the information we need in order to be
maximally well armed against
cyrus cov2 let's do it i really think
there's a lot riding
on if this virus is well known to
somebody
we need to know what they know right
away
the weasel clade includes many humans
that's a t-shirt
no we can't do it we can't do that you
can't do that
but here's the problem is weasels are so
amazing the fact that they are that that
term weasel is used to um yeah sniffling
i've never seen an actual weasel snivel
they don't i mean i've seen them do it
but they do it beautifully they and they
have pride
they're pride of sniveling a whole pride
of weasels that'd be a thing
um yeah so anyway i i don't use the word
weasel that way
i don't think i don't think i'm very
fond of weasels yeah
um but i get your point yeah yeah since
it has been more than a year since
coveted 19 crest into humans does the
who's investigation into the origins of
the virus have any realistic chance of
determining the origin or is this just a
pr operation
well okay does the who's investigation
have any real chance
i don't know i don't know that it was
set up to find out it's certainly
construction oh that's the question
right is it a is it an actual
investigation
or is it a dog and pony show it's hard
for me to imagine that somebody who
wanted to know the answer to the
question and share with the public
would have put peter dashik on
this panel and it's not you know i am by
far not the first person to point out
the lack of credibility
that goes along with that decision
that said i don't think that it being a
year means anything
about what we can know yes some
information has been lost on the other
hand if i can say
you know again the drastic group that
has been working
you know against steep odds and
tremendous
resistance has done an amazing job of
demonstrating things and bringing them
into the public record
and the first thing we can do is
look at what they've produced give it an
honest evaluation
figure out what remains to be known and
you know confront the chinese look
if the chinese had behaved as if they
were innocent on this front
i might be somewhere different i'd be
saying maybe they don't know
maybe this is a coincidence but the fact
that they have behaved in a way that is
consistent
with hiding things and that the evidence
seems to point to gain of function
research
all of the dots seem to come together
well it's at least consistent i mean
it's it's
also possible they don't actually know
they just know that it's possible
right and that you know they're they're
obscuring things just as
you know many american research
researchers are obscuring things
because it it might have been them um i
think that that's almost impossible
why because if sars kovi
ii is the result of serial passage
experiments then i don't
i don't know how the person who had run
those experiments could possibly be
unable to identify that it was
it was their monster um fair enough so
uh so i think if it is theirs
they would know and that
from that much follows
yeah okay
some say that we have a quality of
opportunity already
you say not yet how do we measure it to
know either way and weed out preferences
except to the law and order
no except through the law and other
tools not being fully made
use of such as boycotting actual bigots
it seems like some won't be satisfied
even if we had it that is equality of
opportunity
what do people feel they still can't do
in the current life in weird countries
wouldn't a strategy personalized for
individuals independent of identity
solve that
i mean this is a frequent question asker
um and i think as as is so often the
case we're in um
alignment the question seems to sort of
answer its own
question yeah i mean look equality of
opportunity does not exist
um that doesn't mean that we haven't
made tremendous gains on it but your zip
code
predicts a tremendous amount about where
you'll end up in life
it tells you what your opportunities are
do people from zip codes
that have a more difficult
road ahead beat the odds they do
but but if your zip code
is the most important factor or one of
the most important factors
that determines whether or not you will
be armed with the tools that could
potentially
unleash your potential to innovate and
get paid for it
then that is an inequality worth paying
attention to
to the extent that zip codes are not
evenly distributed among races that
means that you don't need
actual racism to result in race having
strong
implications about your opportunities in
life so
it seems to me quite clear we know that
opportunity isn't evenly distributed we
also know
it can't be perfectly evenly distributed
right and what i've
said before is that what you want is the
unfairness
distributed randomly right to the extent
that it is distributed systematically
that's a problem
however the questioner's point is right
which is
that for many even if we had
equal opportunity it would not be
satisfying in fact wouldn't even be
recognized
um there would be claims you know this
goes back to the point we made
many live streams ago about as a
particular phenomenon grows rare your
sensitivity to it goes up to the point
that even in its absence people see it
everywhere
right but i mean even even your goal
which seems like
many steps uh below utopia which i know
you are a
huge opposition yes um
your goal of distributing unfairness
equally
i cannot be attained um and you know
i think i think this points to part of
why many
of the people on the sort of i insist on
calling it the pseudo left although you
know
it certainly does have historical
precedent on the left
are against things like the family
because
families exactly do concentrate resource
and uh the vast majority of families
don't have so much resource
that uh unfairness can't still knock
people off something but
you know you're not you're not gonna not
let
parents give things to their children
right right that's that's
that's not an okay goal and aside from a
few fringe loonies
on the far left no one thinks it is so
you know un unfairness can be
distributed as equally as possible
but if you are raised middle class you
are going to have access to some more
stuff
than if you were raised lower class yeah
i agree with you
um so what we're uh drilling down
to here is the perfect state can't exist
what you want is the imperfection to be
as perfect as possible
it won't be perfectly perfect right and
so what
at the end of the day what you want is
that which you cannot fix
needs to be within bootstraps of equal
right in other words if you find
yourself on the losing end
of this game of opportunity then the
answer is
you have to be able to overcome that
with something that is under your
control
right right if you ended up on the
losing end then
work hard learn to code and yeah you
know learn to code i mean and that's
that is what things like
you know pell grants exist for right now
you know this is just
my go to example because so many of our
students
had pell grants at evergreen and
specifically
for the mini study abroad programs that
i ran um and
and we ran the last one um
i i came to know very quickly that there
is a federal program to allow
lower income lower income students
to apply for a federal you know a
scholarship at the federal level to do
to do study abroad it's like five
thousand dollars maximum but i ran these
programs
super inexpensively super tight and that
you know
and a huge proportion of my students got
these things
yeah and because you worked with them
because i worked with them because
i i taught them what a good essay would
would be like i worked with them before
i was on salary every year you know
every year that i ran these things
and helped them write applications that
were actually good and reflected who
they were and not who they imagined
these you know mythical creatures who
were reading these
these grant applications would look like
that the gilman scholarship is what it's
called
struck me you know so little money and
it made a
huge difference to every single person
who got one of these gilman scholarships
and
it was just a perfect example of a
great way to distribute to redistribute
opportunity
because the students who came from you
know upper middle class or even middle
class homes
could generally put together the money
given how cheaply i ran these trips
um to to get there themselves
um but some people simply wouldn't have
been able to go a lot of people wouldn't
have been able to go without them
and a lot you know a lot of people who
had never been more than 50 miles
outside of
their hometown never had a passport
nothing i got to drop him into the
middle of you know boca del toro
archipelago or the amazon
and guess what you're never the same
afterwards
yeah and it's for the better all right
in the interest of self-protection i
just want to
finalize that by saying when i say
within a bootstrap
of equality that means
real bootstraps it has to actually it's
not the [ __ ] that people get told
pull yourself up by your bootstraps when
that's not a possibility from where you
are
real bootstrap's distance is the amount
of noise i think we can tolerate in the
system
yes good um
life arose nearly as soon as the earth
cooled off
how can we explain the quickness for
life to arise only seeming to happen
once oh
i think that's a good question i would
say
because once you have life here it tends
to
defeat everything else in the de facto
competition for stuff
so that is to say this was what i came
up with too it's effect it's competitive
exclusion
yes but the thing is it happens even
before you have
anything that looks like it can compete
right the simple tendency to accumulate
material
right means that those things that you
might build a second tree of life
out of um are going to have trouble
sourcing the stuff
yeah um and so you know it's interesting
darwin specifically leaves open the
possibility that there's more than one
tree of life
yeah because he didn't have the
molecular evidence the molecular
evidence allows us to rule out this
possibility
if we exclude things like
prions right which don't have
the dna with which we could say they are
on the tree of life
right so it's there's nothing
contradictory there's just not there
isn't the same confirmatory evidence
it's the confirmatory evidence that says
i don't have to worry
that you know kangaroos and squid are on
two different trees of life before the
lizard people are among us they have the
same
dna code right um
so anyway darwin leaves open the
possibility of multiple trees in the
molecular biology area
era we can say actually everything we
know of
is on the same tree which is amazing
darwin would love to have known that
what we cannot say is that there weren't
other trees at some point right that
left no evidence that we've found
right or the evidence has been
misinterpreted it's just fossil
therefore we can't look at the molecules
i'm not saying that i think this
happened i think the chances are no
other tree
got a foothold because the tree that was
there took all of the opportunities
um but it is it is a fascinating
possibility
and boy would we you know let's put it
this way even the
mammals of you know australia
are sufficiently different and bizarre
relative to the mammals of the rest of
the world
what would an entirely different tree of
life look like and be just such a
delightful thing to know
amazing yeah okay now we have uh just
several
lovely comments that i'm going i'm going
to read because we got enough of them
i think i didn't even capture them all
but
that's not covered we know it's not i
just think it's dusty or something
right uh it's dry is what it's the
airplane isn't it probably
yeah um we're not on an airplane now
we're in a sauna as you can plainly see
but that's why it's dry isn't it yes
it's a dry sauna loved your belmar
segment
here's some federal reserve notes to
keep the lights on and the excellent
content
content going thank you thank you good
to see you on real time
i am 78 living in l.a got my first dose
of the moderna but having trouble
getting an appointment for the second
we have heard this from someone else in
very much
very close to your situation um and that
someone who got
the pfizer is already getting the second
um
so i i don't know what that is about um
and
what's going on with supply chain there
yeah it's uh chaos
yeah my hope and my expectation based on
the underlying immunology
is that um it's not going to be
tremendously sensitive to the exact
period of time
uh yeah it may be it may be quite
sensitive to whether or not you get one
or two
oh yeah and the dosage but the um but
the latency between the two doses
yeah there will be it will decay but my
hope is that it's on a much
larger time scale yeah i just want to
remind everyone how beautiful you both
are and i love you
get get you're here i don't know what
get your hair it means
yeah you're here yeah i don't know what
gets you here hi heather hi brett
uplifting as always here's a fiver in
appreciation best wishes charlie from
somerset uk
thanks charlie thank you and great
mainstream debut you looked and behaved
like expert adult citizens and treated
your audience as such
the politicization science issue was
raised perfectly that's it
big thanks and congrats thank you
snowden bleep
um awesome okay so let's do oh boy
let's do like three more here i'm sorry
we will miss so many and then move into
this hours okay um started following you
oh it's kind of in this it starts with
the comment but um we do get to a
question
started following you guys a few weeks
ago congrats on the tv appearance they
haven't found a vaccine for the original
sars
how can they come up with this and call
it a solution in less than a year
well okay the need to come up with one
for the original sars
decayed because it behaved more like
an emergent uh virus
look we can we cannot doubt
there's something amazing about the
number of vaccines that have arisen
at uh at this point already we've got
extraordinary
we've got four uh that are either
out or on the verge of available and
there are
more than a dozen in active development
i believe there are
26 i think it's 20 something
phase three something like that
anyway this is amazing and in fact some
of them are using the traditional
vaccine technology
yep um the three that we have available
in the u.s are actually i'm not is
astrazeneca
available yet here uh no and there's uh
there's yeah about whether it works
right but yeah so
the mrna vaccines one of their great
positives is that they really can be
developed
like in a weekend and so if they prove
to be safe and effective
they will be a terrific tool in our you
know terrific quiver
in um in our toolkit to
deal with emerging diseases in the
future like really extraordinary
um astrazeneca which is a dna vaccine
um i i believe the dna vaccines can also
be developed somewhat more rapidly than
the traditional vaccines because you
basically just don't have to go through
so many iterations
right you don't have to grow so much
stuff in the lab you don't have to grow
anything in the lab
right um so but you know part of part of
it is
we need it in a way we didn't for sars
cove right for the first stars
and um the second is that you know
really this technology was we hope
right on the cusp being ready and now
it's ready and it's awesome
or was not quite right on the cusp and
we're pushing it
because we need it and who knows but
when was sars
i don't even remember five to ten years
somewhere but you know we didn't have
this technology yet we weren't there
and so the best they could have done if
it seemed necessary was the traditional
vaccine development which takes
years yep so anyway i think
uh if there's one thing this episode has
taught us it's that
there is a capacity when needed to
generate vaccines
very rapidly um there
cannot be a mechanism for
determining their safety that works
rapidly because one question is what's
their effect over time
right i don't see a solution to that
problem other than that these platforms
will begin to tell us how much variation
there is in the safety of different
versions of them
right so are you saying beer is healthy
no however beer will keep you alive
calorie wise
if um if that's what you need most
americans are not strapped for calories
that does not seem to be our problem
and um indeed if you're if you're
watching this
it's a good chance that you have access
to plenty of calories
yes i've heard people say that beer is
uh evidence of god and that he wants us
to be happy
i've been unable to establish whether
that's accurate or not
on account if you can't drink beer can't
drink beer anymore yeah so i guess he
doesn't want me to be happy but
yeah actually gluten intolerance is
evidence that god hates you
it's true that beer is evidence that god
wants people to be happy i'm not taking
it personally yet i just
i'm leaving open the possibility that it
just happened
okay yeah if that if that's what you
need to do to get through
that's that's where i am yeah um our
high heels lordosis behavior
interesting question um so lordosis
is uh the receptive
behavior in female mammals um the
sexually receptive behavior in female
mammals and
heels put the lower back of women into a
position that looks
that is something of the same curve um
you know heels aren't behavior
but is it mimicking the uh
the stance a little is that coincidental
not entirely
probably probably coincidental no
i'm answering the question i'm i'm going
to go with the one word answer i think
probably the implication of the question
is
right that this is the reason that that
uh heels have caught on
and it's not because they're functional
that's for sure that's for sure
all right uh where is this ours
where are the sars questions here we go
oh boy we got a lot of them
okay uh
yeah um i like the stock
says this person um we didn't talk
gamestop at all yes which i think
i think is what this is a reference to
yeah i don't know i can't tell for sure
but um i guess would be
um do we stunk so good
um look here's the thing
what's going on with the redditors and
gamestop this should not be allowed
um but it's so marvelous that it's
happening
this behavior the gaming of the stock
market
but i'm not against this i'm all for
this version or the fact is this is what
goes on
all the time and the fact that it's the
little guys doing it to the big guys
is so delightful it was a crazy place to
start
i just my point is let us
separate our delight at the um
the justice implied in the little guys
ganging up on the big guys
and uh squeezing their shorts as it were
um is that is that the thing that's been
said i like that
well squeezing that modified it's a
short squeeze but
no squeezing their shorts that's good
that's good
um but anyway yeah look this is totally
delightful i don't want us to lose track
of the fact that really what it reveals
is the shenanigans of um these
uh exotic um behaviors in the financial
markets
and that there's a lot of harm done i
mean this you know including the
shorting of uh
stocks the manipulation that these guys
are taking advantage of
on the part of the hedge funds um so
uh it's delightful let's keep in mind
what it is and why it works though
and yep all right maybe we'll revisit it
that goes yeah
uh knock knock who's there biden biden
who
biden my time till unity 2024 gabbard
amash
amash sorry 2024 hashtag gabbard amash
2024. i like gabbard
i like amash yeah it's hard with four
a's in there to get all of the
pronunciations right
it turns out gabbard amash right that's
correct
gabriel dimash yeah yeah anyway well
anyway that'd be an awesome ticket yeah
it would be
excellent people would be excellent
seems
[Music]
seems more stillborn babies are male
does it mean more males are conceived so
sex ratio is conserved
what happens when medicine makes
stillborn deaths decrease
yeah i think probably male
males are more fragile right like males
are more fragile throughout the entire
developmental lifespan from from
inseminate from fertilization to um
to to death so almost certainly given
you know given that we have
a return to a
primary sex ratio of one to one ish at
age of first reproduction yes you will
expect
and and we i can't i don't have the
empirical data at my fingertips here but
you expect that the earlier sex ratios
are biased towards
males such that selection is effectively
getting you to a one-to-one sex ratio
at age of first reproduction so
men are more fragile but we're not going
to cry about it
right that's the nature of men yep um
so first off there
we can talk a little bit mechanistically
about why it might be
that males are more often stillborn
could be that um the fact that females
have a redundant x
and males have only one x means that
males are
more sensitive to the possibility of a
defect on their one x that is not
compensated by anything on the y
because there's very little on the y
there's also
maybe correlated to this something
called haldane's rule
that says i'll try to get it right that
when
there is a hybrid if one of the sexes
is going to be uh sterile
defective or dead i think are the three
um it's going to be the heterogametic
sex
please tell me i've got held and scroll
ryan absent rare or sterile
absent rare or sterile it's going to be
the heterogametic sex that is in
a system like ours the xy so
this is consistent it's not the hybrid
but the idea is
um what you've got is male showing a
kind of fragility
that were we talking about hybrids would
predict
the absence of males the sterility of
males or
stillbornness um so anyway it's all kind
of consistent
and um i'd be very curious whether the
pattern
uh is true in let's say birds which have
the
opposite where uh females are
heterogametic
yes so many of these questions about
what's going on
in humans with the greatest sex
differences uh we should be looking at
emus or something
we should be looking at emails let's go
all right
as soon as the live stream is done okay
um
talk more about the new mrna vaccine
lipid delivery system
dangers resources papers how deep have
you dug how happy to see you all on mar
um we talked about it a fair bit
in episode 58 i think and we do have
some references up there
uh including at least one paper that's
specifically about the development of
the
nlp is the no no the lnp is the lipid
nanoparticles
um the one thing i think that i said
in that live stream is that the
particulars are as you would expect
proprietary so
um there is there's a fair bit of stuff
that you can find on
you know the history of using these
lipid nanoparticles it's not that deep
it's not a deep history but um but in
terms of what particular thing is being
used
in either of these vaccines that are
using them we don't
i i think still it's true that we don't
know yeah which i find questionable
i understand in a world where things are
financed in the way that they are
that you know that uh there
there is proprietary information but on
the other hand we're being asked
to you know take these injections and
having full information on what's there
so that we can actually parse
how frightened to be of it or not um
seems
uh fair play and there have got to be
other ways to to protect intellectual
property in this case
i would think yes i agree
to any newbies from tv land thinking oh
my god a conversation instead of yelling
sound bites
hit the like button and share it
increases exposure thank you
we can do yelling sound bites no we
can't
all right you win that one i i think i
did a terrible job actually yeah it was
not very convincing no uh where do you
see humanity in a million years
oh i'm sorry
humanity in a million years um you're a
bad person
wow oh do i wait if i yelled that does
that work you're a bad person
a million years okay i look i'm i'm
gonna be
grateful if we're here in a million
hours
i just you are a bad person ah it's
not an easy thing to do given our level
of technology and our
hubris and our um
love of uh trying new things and
gambling everything on them
um so i look
i want us to figure our way through this
very dangerous period
and i i just
um apropos conversation that we had
yesterday which
i will leave nameless
who it was with um but also apropos
my own um science fiction interests
and and what i have written um my
thought
is actually consistent with yours but
for the possibility
uh that we have managed to to expand
to colonize um not within the solar
system
that there's there's no place to go
within the solar system that's going to
be stable long term
um but that some kind of technology has
allowed for super
luminal travel such that we can actually
explore and find new places to be and in
that case
it's possible that humanity might still
be going in a million years you still
don't think so
well here's the thing okay look you want
to be here in a million hours
first priority fusion power
and the political intelligence to manage
it so it doesn't become just another
weapon for
those with power against those who don't
have it okay
that solves a huge fraction of our
current
problems how long have we been staring
down the barrel of fusion and
unable to get there we're not even
confused about how to do it
we know how to do fusion it's just
technically hard
right really yeah so the point is
this is a technology everybody not only
is there an
immense financial incentive to get it
right
but there's a ton riding on it in terms
of what we can do you want to reverse
global warming
fusion's the way to do it right we know
this
and yet we can't get there it's that
hard right
so my sense is you know is there
a trick that would actually allow human
beings to be somewhere very distant
uh you know breaking the the speed limit
of the universe
as we know it um i'm very skeptical
of the idea that even if the loophole
exists
that it can be exploited i don't think
it's going to be
you know simple like fusion
and fusion is so hard that it has been
you know looming over the horizon for
decades
so i just don't see this as a solution
to a short-term problem
at all i can't see it well um
i wasn't asked to i don't read the
question as uh
how do you get there like if you've
gotten there where do you where you see
us
oh so then the question is unfortunately
where i see us as
stuck is not very much wisdom
about the fact that when you have
technologies that are capable
you know let's say lab leak
is clearly a possibility forget whether
sarsko v2
is such a thing sure you could with
present technology
take a virus massively upgrade its
capacity to infect and do harm
and you could release it okay that's a
technology that exists
we clearly don't have the wisdom to
figure out what to do with a planet full
of people
where the price point on doing such a
thing is dropping you know by the year
right likewise nuclear fission
right likewise ai all of these things
are technologies that we just simply
went with the opposite of the
precautionary principle so
where do i see us in a million years
i see us having not made it across the
gap
right there's a gap where we've got the
technology to kill ourselves off
and we don't have the wisdom to
recognize the hazard that we've seen
across that gap is how why we don't get
to a million years right
okay right so that is to say if there
was some so i'm saying like i'm i mean
this is
this is in fact exactly what i did in
the in the draft of the science
fiction novel that i've written is i've
said
that's a black box yeah we got to the
gap if we got through the gap we really
got through the gap
and now here we go right oh and um
you know this is uh eric's point about
uh
his hypothesis of everything and the
potential
that's the criticism this is the
conversation i was referring to earlier
yes yeah
uh but my sense is is the speed limit
breakable
i'm all ears if it is breakable
is it breakable by something like a
person
i'm willing to believe that
theoretically such a thing is
conceivable
but well i mean if as i understand it
eric's right doesn't require breaking
the speed limit
it's about it's about different
dimensionality sure yeah
but um you know i don't know what he
said where so
we'll just uh leave it oblique but
i'm willing to understand that there
could be such a possibility
what i'm skeptical of is that that
possibility is not
a high-tech possibility right and if
that is a high-tech possibility
then the question is how hard is it
compared to
going to mars because it turns out that
you cannot extrapolate linearly from the
ability to go to the moon
and say you know how much farther is
mars right it doesn't work like that
right likewise fusion
you know fusion is technically not that
complex in practice it's massively
difficult
right um so anyway there it is
the story the story of body plan of
echinoderms is even more interesting
think about sea cucumbers which appear
to evolve towards bilateral symmetry
again
yeah although i don't know i don't have
an echinoderm phylogeny in my head or
easily
to pull up so i don't my guess would be
the most parsimonious hypothesis would
be that they never
went radial right like that they were
just um they're basically bilaterally
symmetrical just like sea stars are
and then it sees stars who went radial
and um everyone else in that clade
stuck with the left right scene that
we've got i
like it a phylogenetic prediction which
we can
test right after the live stream see
what the latest is wait i thought we're
going to go see emos oh yeah
sorry okay after the email make a list
zack you keeping a list
of course good uh but pl oh brett
please consider a run for prez we need
civility nuanced thought a path forward
we will support you groundswell for
unity 2024
weinstein2024
um yeah that's not a it's not a good job
dude you're a patriot i i would do it if
i had to
[Music]
um don't wanna
yeah we can do better
you me and tim pool are political
opposites but find common cause
will this be the catalyst i don't know
what will this be the catalyst means and
it's interesting i don't know i don't
know who this is
um but interesting to imagine
us this person and tim poole
political opposites like a three-way
political opposite and you know tim
used to be anyway um we had we had a lot
in common with tim poole's view of the
world yeah i think that has
changed somewhat recently but um i
wouldn't i don't think of him as an
opposite
yep yeah um
thanks much here we go thanks much for
sharing brett's last evergreen class
speech
very prescient we are now truly heading
towards a first against the wall club
we need a place for the center to stand
perhaps unity 2020
no perhaps unity 2022 love you guys
uh yeah there's room for a lot of unity
um i would just caution there's a lot of
unity's coming up here
um in the context of
elections and i see it as every bit as
viable in such a context as we've seen
before but they're
you know to me unity is about
whatever the uh patriotic best option
would be
and that's not always about electing
people teams any of those things
it can be that but it can also be much
more than that and i think we just have
to start
thinking about what options are in front
of us that we can't take for political
reasons and then how to make those
things
politically viable yeah okay so we're
going to get through
five more here a couple of them are just
uh comments
or short questions just fyi proponents
of the carnivore diet find red meat to
be the least inflammatory food
or at least far less than many
vegetables yeah i know this actually i
know this is i
so i was quoting this research and i
did not chase down the reference that
they were um
that they were referencing uh when so
the claim was that uh gluten wheat and
alcohol are all inflammatory and of
course there's also
it's true that um what is it in red wine
that is an anti-inflammatory
yeah um so you know it's not but it
seems to like overcome
the inflammatory part and actually red
wine
in moderation um is supposed to be
somewhat anti-inflammatory so
my guess would be that the
um you know the carnivore diet
has never struck me you know an entirely
carnivore diet has ever struck me as
likely to be healthy for all but
um very few lineages of humans but that
there is something about some
combination
just like there is with wine that it's
not just like red meat bad or red meat
good
um but that i mean among other things
for sure
is that red meat of animals that ate
like their ancestors did
as opposed you know grass fed and
grass-finished not grass-fed and then
grain finished
and not corn-fed and you know all of
that beef
is going to be far healthier for you and
my guess would be anti-inflammatory
potentially
whereas corn-fed beef probably highly
inflammatory so that's gonna be a big
part of it
so it's also possible and i don't know
this is probably known
not to me but um it's also possible that
the because mammals are inherently going
to be closer to
us that they are less triggering
of immune cascades involved in
inflammation
so um in other words to the extent that
we have a self-non-self-recognition
system
that uh works in a narrow sense but it
may be that it
uh there's a carryover effect that the
distance causes
a greater triggering of the system but i
would say although i don't think anyone
claims fish are inflammatory eating fish
i think like chicken like poultry tends
to get on that list which would fit with
what you're saying but i don't i
i agree yeah so anyway so open question
i would say though
red meat is not universally uh
non-inflammatory
for sure in flames vegetarians
ah yes i've seen many
irate over not being able to eat red
meat
that's probably what's happening they're
just hungry but yeah um
but yeah something about that yeah um
cue for you guys question for you guys
god this is so tiny and i can't zoom in
for some reason
um question for you guys is parents and
educators
how can i help my son who is very gifted
but has short attention span and poor
follow-through on assigned
tasks boy yeah there's no hope for those
kinds
[Laughter]
you're looking at one yeah um and yeah
so
i don't want to give this question short
shrift um you know we have
we had two whole education chapters in
our book and we cut it down into one
although there's both a childhood
chapter and a school school in higher ed
chapter
still um so i don't know if you have a
blurb to say here yeah there are a
couple things one i'm not sure i ever
had um
low attention span i'm not even sure
well that's what they would have said
yeah i mean you were just at the border
of like you did get
uh prescribed ritalin because they
weren't quite doing that yet well not
when i was a kid they tried that later
and i didn't take it and
it was garbage and i wouldn't but um
cheek pouched it
i just left it in a drawer um
but in any case the the big
hidden question here is about the
mismatch between the kid
and the stuff and the fact that your kid
doesn't pay attention for long maybe
about the fact that the stuff isn't all
that compelling to them
and what i would say is um
branch out and see if you can figure out
what
jazz is the kid right maybe it's guitar
maybe it's arduino
maybe it's bicycling yeah so i mean
bicycling isn't academic the other two
can be
well but any of these things right if
you can get passionate about
something and you know if it's bicycles
then you know
learn to build one right that's awfully
thought-provoking and it will teach you
a lot of stuff and the basic point is
the capacity to do things is
translatable between
realms the hard part is getting a
an environment that rewards the right
stuff so that you actually build up
capacity
and they're now some great tools as
heather points out
arduino if your kids into the idea of
building
robot stuff or boxes that do things or
making inventions
the world is their oyster at this moment
right you can just literally order off
the internet
stuff that they can build into whatever
they do stuff that is so good
that actually the adult world has gone
crazy with this they're doing all kinds
of stuff people are building their own
experimental apparatus and vehicles and
all sorts of things so
um if that's not your kid's bag
then find something that is and the real
question is can you beat the
motivational issue
right you don't want to bore your kid to
tears you want something that they
they want to strive for something
because it's desirable to them and it's
enough to get them to invest
in building the capacity to get there
okay um three more here
i am a simple man i see a q a stream i
send a super chat how is the
revolutionary phenotype reading going so
that's the second question we got about
that today
yeah we have we we're not there yet
that's how it's going
sorry about that um we are in a
homeschooling group of about 12 young
kids
they're outside playing together
undirected most of the day the change in
behavior and health has been dramatic
not sure if you'll send them back to
school now can you speak to if play
is as important thank you
yeah yeah it should it should all be
played right into calculus
yeah you know at some age there's a
certain amount of formal stuff
that depending on what they want to be
able to do in the world
actual an effective formal education
is going to be probably a better choice
but um
certainly that isn't through elementary
school i would say
um and you know there will be people who
argue with me about literacy and math
and you know what
your kids growing up you know you're
writing a super chat question that reads
that way they're not going to grow up
illiterate
right yeah um the problem is the stuff
isn't designed as play the fact that the
play works is great
to the extent that you can get stuff
that isn't ordinarily delivered in that
form delivered in something closer to
that form great to the extent that you
can rewire so that
stuff that other people find to be
boring is
energizing to you great yeah i mean play
is practice for adulthood play
is practice for whatever and you know we
play as adults
as humans and you know some some other
long-lived generational overlap social
creatures do as well
and what it is is practicing for what
other kinds of things you might want to
do
so um you know expand the boundaries of
what play can look like
and play is absolutely fundamental you
take play out of life
and don't be surprised when you end up
with
people who are addicted to screens and
drugs
yep absolutely screens and pills
like pharmaceuticals specifically
um
i thought this was the time miss one one
two three four okay so last
question last question um is it sad that
i would trust
pete townsend and roger daltrey more
than the researchers being sent to china
good one um no i
it's it's yes it's it's sad but not for
you
yeah look we're not allowed to say the
obvious
right people are human right when they
have a conflict of interest
it's not an accusation to say that they
should be kept
out of something now uh in this case
you know peter dasher should have
recused himself the fact that he didn't
is conspicuous
the fact that he was on the list of
people being sent is conspicuous and it
raises the question about what the point
of the exercise is
what people are not getting is
we the people of earth have a right to
know what the hell happened and if what
the hell happened
is a bat infected a mink farm
fine if it's a bat infected a civet
fine if it's that it came out of the lab
not so great but we need to know
now and you know what do we have to do
to get an honest inquiry
how much would have to be riding on the
answer right people are still treating
this as if
the answer to the question is irrelevant
to our success against the virus and
there is
no reason to think that that's right it
is likely to be highly relevant
yes all right well that's uh we've come
full circle ish yeah we always end on a
pete townsend question
it came just in the nick of time it
certainly it certainly did
yep um all right so uh for those of
you who are um interested in yet more q
a tomorrow we'll be
um here with a private q a at 11 a.m
pacific for people who have joined at my
patreon
um before our live stream next week you
will be having your
um 100 patreon conversation from 10 to
12
uh pacific um
let's see what else discord server is
accessible on both of our patreons
we have merchandise available at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org with a 10
sale all weekend with a what was the
code i've forgotten what the code was
the code to get the 10 discount is
remember to code
it's not the code buy blues all caps b
y e b l u e s
um you can email
darkhorse.moderategmail.com for
logistical questions ah
speaking of one more thing uh which is
that last week
you dropped in casually that we might be
interested
in um in hiring an illustrator to do
some of the merchandise going forward
and our moderator reports that the
uh that the response has been
unbelievable
uh really really like so much
amazing stuff in contributions but it
just keeps flowing in so
um if you didn't hear that before and
you're hearing it for the first time now
okay you can still send stuff into dark
or stop moderator but really this
message is
not asking for more submissions it's
saying please be patient
uh we may not get through all of it and
uh we haven't even begun to look yet but
you know thank you for the enthusiasm
and uh we look forward to looking at
them absolutely
yeah all right i think we've reached the
end reached the end we'll be here next
week
and we'll see you be well everybody
you